Speaker 1: But not to be outdone, folks,
as I mentioned Florida trying to give in to
Trump's crazy demands to in our Trump loving
governor Ron DeSantis over here in Florida
is asking the state legislature
to give him two million dollars
so that he can create an office of
election crime and security next year.
Now he is urging the state legislature to give
him this new office when they resume their
session next year. Obviously, it's not going to
happen in 2021, unfortunately for him. But again,
Trump has demanded that we do some audits here
in Florida. Only of the areas Biden won, the
five counties Biden won in South Florida, the big
ones. And Ron DeSantis said, Sure. Let me go. Talk
to the Legislature. I just got to get about $5
million. I got a higher roughly 50 people. So, you
know, it's going to be good is going to be a job
creating thing, right? We're going to have a new
Florida agency, 49 permanent staffers whose sole
focus is going to be looking into voter fraud.
Yeah, I imagine there's going to
be some downtime at that office.
So, hey, if you're in the state of Florida looking
for a job or you don't really have to do much,
maybe wait and see if this new office gets created
because that would be the job for you because the
problem we have here is that actually there is
voter fraud in Florida. We found three cases.
Just last week, it was revealed. All three of them
from the retirement community called the villages.
And all three of them, Republicans. See, this is
why Trump and DeSantis and Abbott over in Texas,
this is why you all got to be careful what
you wish for. The vast majority of the voter
fraud cases that have been found from the 2020
election have been Republicans voting twice.
Obviously, some of the more notable cases we
have the man who voted for his deceased mother.
Used her ballot, voted for Trump man who voted
for his deceased wife, used her ballot to vote for
Trump. The three people down in the villages that
it was revealed last week, they voted here in the
state of Florida. They also voted absentee from
other states. It didn't say who they voted for,
but they're all registered Republicans, so we
don't have to really even use our imaginations
to wonder how those votes went. And according
to new reports, they think there's even more
voter fraud that took place in the
villages, which is predominantly Republican.
So, Ron DeSantis, I'm going to tell you this man,
I am actually OK with you creating this division.
I truly am. Because voter fraud does need to
be addressed if it exists. And if you want to
devote time and resources to it than doing it, you
better find some voter fraud here in the state of
Florida. And according to the reports, according
to an ongoing investigation, apparently the
first place you need to go are those retirement
communities where it is predominantly Republicans.
Because that seems to be where the fraud is
running rampant. Much like the other things
that have been running rampant in the villages,
if you don't know what I'm getting at, I suggest
you Google it. It is at one point at least one
of the highest rates of STDs in the country. But
when they're not doing that, apparently some
of them are committing voter fraud as well.
And that's what we're dealing with here in
the state of Florida. But let's not pretend
for a second that voter fraud is actually
a real problem, that we need to be devoting
millions and millions and millions of dollars and
thousands and thousands and thousands of hours
towards fixing. Are there cases out there?
Heck yeah, we found plenty this year. I mean,
we found a couple of handful of them.
Let's be real. Most of them are Republican.
So if you all want to root it out. If you want
to put your own people in jail, fine by me,
I'm not going to stop you. But if you want to
pretend that our elections are somehow unsafe
because of all the fraud, that's where I draw
the line because the evidence tells us otherwise.
I'm Farron Cousins. You can get me on
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram at fair and
balanced youtube.com slash the ring of Fire Own
podcast dot com. We'll be right back with more.